歡迎收看最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李肇華
好 今天台股出現那個比較明顯的回檔
盤中疊點有超過600點
算是一路反彈以來稍微稍微的修正一下
但是到這邊其實有一個很關鍵的意義
也許抵檔超低的現在想要賣一些
也許反彈有點解套的也想賣一些
但更重要的叫做成仙啟後
什麼叫成仙啟後
我們知道第二季的財報跟半年報
應該原則上沒問題的都全數出爐了
成績是好到不得了
而最近揮達也是動作頻頻喔
最新的就是
他要再一輪的注資給OpenAI
我們知道 OpenAI
就是所謂的AI擁動機的那個縱子頭
他注資給他
而 OpenAI 就有可能提早轉歸為營
這些事情對台股
都有非常重大往後看的意義
我們站在那麼好的財報成績上
如果下半年到明年
我們的持續成長訂單會進來的話
好 台股反彈到這邊
休息一下就是準備喝了再上
來歡迎今天的三位來賓
第一位是 AI 達人蔡明翰
看到明翰就知道
我們要來幫揮達 OpenAI
這一串的龍頭大廠們
還有新創公司們
來講一下 AI 沒有泡沫化的問題
錢投進去確實有回收
等一下證據拿出來
不只台股的 EPS 在往上衝
每股的 EPS 也在往上衝
尤其我們的半年報出來
第二季的財報
哇 年增率170%
這麼亮眼的數據
但明漢會幫您往下推
有沒有誰現在是財報好
整個表現強勢值得追
或者是才報好
超級委屈值得減
等一下幫您說分明囉
第二位是
古期雙分析師紀瑋銘小明同學
小明也要講
明天台紙期結算
今天算不算是提早
有一點壓低呢
壓低後有一個事情很重要
外資在8月是大買台股的
因為台幣走槍
今天因為台幣沒有走槍
所以外資沒有大買
可是結算過後
外資的買盤回來
排骨會產生一個事情
擴散效應
例如反彈上來的CPU
先轉移線均
接下來跟CPU相關的中低價股
應該也會啟動
設備股訂單滿手
現在算是盤面上
本一筆相對合理
未來展望也強勁的
等一下幫您挑
第三位是我們的
選股教練黃金右下角
維泰
看到維泰就知道
維泰的第一個任務
來救火救什麼火
旺戲為什麼開完法說會後
兩根疊停板
難道過去這麼看好他的外資
法人們不認同了嗎
最近報告還在上調目標價
而視星ky也是一樣
一直在回檔
所以這兩檔公司發生什麼問題
幫您講
但是呢
排面上有一些黃金又下腳
例如散熱
已經有人表態快要逼近前高的情況下
今天回檔裡面有很多便宜的好公司
散裝 貨櫃航運
今天一起來這個維泰有研究
告訴您運價會高到哪裡去
好首先有請我們明翰
明翰今天來
我們又回到了同一題
輝達跟OpenAI的湧動機
好
輝達要決定繼續注資給OpenAI
提供融資金額非常大
台幣4兆以上
這些訂單最後來台股之外
也不要這麼覺得
他們只是在燒錢
他們也有賺錢
所以今天還一併來幫我們做
第二季的財報重提件
好 應該這樣講
這論點還是沒有太大的改變
我們就講到說
目前的角度
應該黃仁軒
因為透過這NVDR的部分
要去支援這個OpenAI
其實這個故事已經一年多了
這故事就一直講到說
就是我覺得這是揮達該做的
因為他為了要讓他的營運
能夠越來越穩健
應該說他找他的客戶
年作度越來越高
所以呢他黃仁軒也提到
這整個OpenAI
有機會帶來6000億美元的商機
那這個就是湧動機的問題
人家講循環融資
但是黃仁勳就說這不是
但是我個人覺得
這個是不是我覺得不是那麼重要
我們等一下後面會再講
重點是這個借出去
到底有沒有很大的風險
回過頭來應該說
他們只要持續投入台股的部分
就是一個很大的利機
我覺得這個到底他們投入對台股
是不是就是一個很好的利機
我覺得實質上是對的
但我覺得股價不要降下
因為我應該提到
我們股價而言等於是
台股跟美股是綁在一起的
你不要說美股他丟錢
他砸錯了 最後他跌我們漲
這事情是不可能發生的
看得到貨利會大增漲
但不代表股價會漲
但目前的角度
確實第二季的財報非常的諒言
貨利王這台積電
這個所謂的7千多億
那是歷史新高
這前五名宏海南亞科聯電廣達
除了宏海之外都是創歷史新高
所以第二季上市季總獲利創歷史新高
應該不意外
大家要留意就是轉期往就是南亞科
他南亞科是獲利第三名
重點是他沒辦法去算YY
因為去年他是虧損
你就知道有多誇張
去年還在虧損
今年是爆賺到這個第三名
所以你就知道記憶體
現在的這個獲利層面有多強
再講到今天出現比較明顯的壓迴
大家可能有點緊張
還好把600點對不對
可是會覺得很莫名其妙
你要知道說開的時候是開紅
然後也不知道發生什麼事情
因為最主要關鍵點
是因為昨天的廢半還在往上漲
所以今天大家滿心期待
但是有一個問題
我覺得我們漲額比較快是沒有關係的
但是有一個很大的問題
我們再上去就要準備要挑戰歷史新高
我就覺得你先漲沒有關係
可是你先創歷史新高我不知道
外資市場能不能接受
放大出頭鳥
會有那個
觀念所以我剛剛講我們先站上月線先站上季線壓力
還沒有那麼大
但是如果我們先創歷史新高我就覺得會有很大的壓力
所以暫時震盪我覺得是一個合理的現象尤其
技術面一直反彈一直反彈到連續三天沒有再過高大家就會開始有點怕
自然會引發獲利了解賣壓我覺得是合理
但是你要記得一件事情
就上半年漲上來是因為獲利
因為我們等一下會講到財報
你就知道多厲害
這修正是技術面
所以代表的後續就算有壓迴
其實空間也不會太大
完全是技術面的震盪而已
所以整體架構來講
大家倒是不用緊張
他在講整體的EPS的架構
第二季的一個狀況
他很特別 他用SMP500
去排除能源類股
先看一下灰色
就是整個獲利的狀況成長度
但扣除AI的就會在這裡
好處是什麼
確實他有足跡成長
從去年第四季到今年第一季 第二季
已經在慢慢好轉
所以整個S&P500的美股本來就是真相
但是如果單看的AI就是藍色組裝圖
你就知道這個年增率
有AI跟沒AI一個54一個14
你就知道整個架構還是靠AI在貢獻
這個是大型雲端業者
就是四大雲端業者
它好處是什麼
就是他們兩年前就已經快速投入
那記得剛剛那是整體公司
看起來比例不高
但是如果整體雲端業者的故事
可能不一樣
你先看到這兩個
這兩個比較特殊
第一個是他們AI的營收
去處理資本支出
所以到底如果營收一直往上
資本支出不業
它就越來越大
但是如果呢
這個資本支出快的
速度太快
就會導致這個數值變小
因為看到這幾年確實有往下
雖然幅度不大
但是之前在0.9
現在剩下0.7
代表什麼意思
就是我個結論就是這個AI應收有在增加
但是資本支出增加的速度還是比營收快
所以現在大家其實很怕就是這一塊
但是如果你看到藍色圖你就知道
藍色圖是代理約的訂單
簡單來講你拿到多少訂單再加上資本支出
但是如果這個對處
會發現它是不斷往上走高
結論就是如果看到資本支出
對現在的營收
其實營收追不上資本支出
但訂單遠比資本支出大很多
所以代表未來這個訂單
會慢慢的一定會變營收
所以現在跟不上進度其實還好
重點你又一直看到
這個履約訂單的情況下
代表的未來應該都有辦法
跟變成營收的情況下
大家就不會害怕
當然之前這個代履約訂單
很多人也擔心啊
會不會給巴拉票什麼的
可是輝達現在出來做主了
不管怎樣我會給你錢
所以應該在旅約上的問題也不會那麼大
是 尤其是我剛剛講的
你說訂單會不會是把他票
我這樣講
就是說如果你今天中小型公司
我覺得機率還高
你跟這個四大雲端業者做生意
不是你說我隨便去下個單啊
跟他開開玩笑
另外一個很重要
就是他有提到這個是去年底的狀況
就雲端業者佔比大概65%
接近65%
三分之二都是雲端業者
和輝達上市法說就有提到
他這一塊雲端業者剩下一半左右
另外一半就是小型的雲端
還有大型的企業
另外一個就是各國的政府
這三大塊
所以下禮拜法說
他的這塊餅
就是他的業金面一定會持續擴大
但有一個很重要
就是這個左邊這塊的占比
是不是還能夠維持一半
代表的
這代表什麼意義
就是今年
大家看到雲端業者
資本資助是用噴出的
可是你有沒有想到
他在噴出的過程當中
他居然秉變小
代表什麼意思
就是這一塊噴出的速度
比他更快
這也是我們說像我們看到
Ensobic或是像OpenAI
如果能夠更早轉灰為營
就是接棒的人來了
是
那這樣講都是一樣問題
就是你今天能夠快速獲利
你未來投入你就會更勇敢
回過頭來常常講
擔心7月你會
7月下也會害怕
就是因為你對營收跟獲利
可能信心不夠
對 信心不夠
掌控的沒有那麼準確
這一次出來
總金額是創立指針高
而且年增173%
是一個不可思議的數字
但原因在哪裡
因為你要知道
你對的機器是設定
去年Q2是一個很搭照吧
對
真的是我們兩個都覺得黑天惡的時刻
很慘的時間
所以剛好因為一個超強
去對比一個當時表現
有點突擠的時間
所以看到
所以我常常講
對比營收會比較公平
但也不是完全不能參考
你最基本來講
你講絕對值還就是創高
年增率非常恐怖
但是我會覺得慢慢的應該說
你要大家可以了解
三四應該都還會走高
但對應的這個所謂的機器
就會慢慢墊高
所以大家倒是不用太考慮
我覺得不用太考慮所謂年增率
但是要的是能夠持續增長
我覺得很重要
至於產業的部分
剛剛提到整個均值是173
上個禮拜講的營收的強勢無大族群
幾乎大部分都是符合這個
所謂的獲利大漲的相關的族群
電子通路 電子領主建範導體
電腦周邊
當然有一些
甚至還比均值稍微低一點
但我覺得不重要
因為圖形來講
他們是穩定增長
除了每一次的電子之外
我覺得這幾個是可以留意
代表對股市來講
也是一個非常正向的方向
那我們首先
就來看一個比較難以解說的
就是記憶體
為什麼 因為如果以財報來看的話
剛剛講到記憶體
就是一個大爆發
在第二季的狀況
可是以股價來看
我們現在有全世界最強的記憶體
就是南亞科
它是一個一直在創新高的公司
但其他呢
像模組這些的什麼時候會跟呢
好 我們這樣講
我就跟大家提到
我們先講
它的南亞科的股價
長線而已還是會跟爆價會有點相關
等於說去年建高之後
他就進入整理
然後後續轉強要轉強
比較好的現象在哪裡
就是最近突破氣球
這確實不斷的走高
他報價在創立行高
所以股價強制 看似合理
所以我覺得
南亞科可不可以操作可以
但是你要持續觀察這個報價
是不是會有出現反轉的可能性
反正目前來講
就是延續上來現在是88.9
你每天打開
他就有更新的數據
所以你只要每天
能夠持續盯著報價
他只要比這個高
代表他這個股價會走高沒有問題
但是要提醒大家
現在的這個記憶體
已經不再像之前的
因為之前的特色是什麼
南亞科是製造
而且南亞科華邦電
旺宏大家一起長完
之外還包含了模組IC
就是所謂記憶IC包含風策通路
所有都會一起長
這次沒有
就是我們抓一個
所謂IC的一個代表
就是群聯
法說會講完是往下的
然後不只這個
就是剛剛提到的摸珠場封測
最近都沒有表現之外
包含製造裡面的南亞科
包含旺紅也都是弱的
都不整齊
就華邦電跟旺紅
沒有跟的那亞科那麼強
對 然後簡單來講創高
大家都在
現在有一個問題
就是全台灣的市場要買記憶體
就是往這邊
就是買南亞科
法人也買南亞科
對
所以相對上是有一點
第一個
他沒辦法擴散
這是一個風險
第二 所謂真正的大廠
美光三星海利是也都沒有創高
所以大家都還在之前的前高之下
只有他創高
那結論我剛剛提到的就是
長線的我會建議這邊就不要再追了
短線可以操作 但把握兩大原則
第一個就是每天看包家
第二就直接買南亞科
不要買其他的股掌
因為他就是一個短線
後續如果報價沒辦法再往上了
你可能就要有一點點風險意識
我要先跟大家提到
這個整個記憶體的一個方向
那除了剛剛提到的記憶體
我們這個是幫大家排所謂的
記報非常亮眼的個股
其中包含毛利
營業利益 稅後利益
三個都創歷史新高
那這個是過去財報
七月營收公布
他也創歷史新高
全部通通歷史新高的公司
對 就是不是講過去
過去三層都創歷史新高
包含剛公佈第三劑的也創高的
所以代表他連續劇還在繼續
連續劇
你會發現剛才提到的
群聯威剛就是記憶體
所以他們倆很委屈對不對
對 但是我老實說
就是他們現在看似有價值
可是我還是建議直接買南亞科
會比較好
至於我們換個角度
如果持有的我會建議
真的稍微忍耐一下
因為他們照理講
因為好處就是我們剛剛提到
報價來上漲
所以壓力應該不會太大
另外包含川湖它滑軌嘛
然後我們可以看到包含亞翔
半導體工程
聯亞的光通訊
然後系格的風策
京居
PCB的風筒
八輛PCB專孔機
還有這個半導體設備
還有信華
然後臺光店 京向店
其實
老實講散佈在各個產業
個股比想像的多
我自己會很多重複的
我會從產業裡面抓一個豬來做代表
其實比這個圓米還多
只是我抓一些比較重要的代表
然後跟大家提到這些真的是
獲利年增率也都非常漂亮的族群
尤其剛剛提到
這些都還不是只有過去
包含第三季都還在創高
所以我覺得個股的部分
有很大的表現落差
那其中一樣跟PCB有關的
臺光電創高
對 獲利很好就創高了
所以我覺得合理
你可以看到營收創高 獲利創高
但是金像電位置就低很多
就低很多
他明明也都是創高朋友棒
對 而且這一段時間一路問
一路問
金箱店到底發生
我說沒事
看你敢不敢買
你要給自己一點信心
因為基本面就真的很好
那我也不知道
到底會跌到哪裡
我也不清楚
會不會再回測 我也不知道
我只能說
就這個個股整個族群
確實往上
而且他的財報很漂亮
而且營收也在創高
要自己要如果了解
就有點信心買的
就不會害怕
過一段時間
該還給他的公道還是會還給他
臺灣唸最常傳出的鬼故事就是
被人家搶單啦
輝達可能在規格上沒有要提得那麼快啊
那金像電就是他在採購一些原料的時候
他有受到漲價的一些問題干擾
所以各自有各自的
一些市場的傳聞這樣
但我覺得啦 只要記得一點
就是CCL他是最大
他是最大的
PCB的裡面他最大
所以你說他被取代
我可能覺得困難度很高
他是在採購上面大家會想
可是畢竟在獲利上
還是繳出了創新高的成績
這邊謝謝明翰
謝謝
好 明翰又好清楚的講了一件事情
我們把脈絡釐清一下
當然大家都擔心
AI會不會持續的支出
但是沒有回收
現在看起來並不是
美國的雲端業者
甚至新創的公司等等
他們接收到了訂單
他們也都有所謂獲利的回收
只是拿到了時候又會再做投入
那硬體廠商現在投資評價
還是凌駕於軟體之上
自對台廠就是一個最好的支撐
他確實也反映在我們第二季的季報上面
創出了一個不可思議的年增率
即使是因為去年機器也許也比較低的關係
但從這裡面來分的話就知道
所有的數據通通創新高的公司
未接有高有低
剛剛幫您分了
如果您喜歡價值的
當然您可以等一下
但是如果喜歡追強
希望有效率的話
就找產業裡面又是龍頭
形態又好的公司
這樣就對了
那廣告回來
小明同學要上場啦
好 明天要臺紙期結算
今天就稍微先做壓低
但值得留意的一件事情
不只是外資的空單要不要補
是現貨要不要買
因為如果現貨持續買
臺股的擴散效應
就會慢慢呈現囉
不曉得大家是不是都在等回檔
找買點呢
這邊有一個比較好的訊息
自然就是外資在8月份
是持續的買超台股
而且除了領頭反彈的一線均之外
像CPU 設備
他們都有所謂的擴散效應
來請教小明同學啦
這就要問你啦
是不是今天壓低結算
明天如果再壓低
那外資回頭有機會
重新再來一次拚錢高
今天講的是CPU跟設備股
對 我們其實在今天大家看到說
在結算前一天
然後指數就壓下來
是不是提早壓低結算
我認為其實算啦
因為我們在今天雖然圖沒有放出來
我可以告訴大家
以未平倉量來講
明天結算的價格大概落在4萬6千點附近
那還蠻高點的
對 就是比今天還要來得更高
所以你說今天是不是壓低結算
我覺得這個我可以回答算是比較偏Yes
但是我們更在意的是
在今天即便大跌
外資它回補了空單
雖然回補一點點
但至少它沒有大幅度做空
另外我們看到的是在散戶為台的部分
原本在昨天看到只剩下7千多口的多單
心裡面就在開心了
胎骨要繼續長了
結果今天開高走低以後
盤中那個時候我就想說完蛋
今天這個地方一定會有多單大增
果然盤後一看增加了17000多口
但我還是要再次強調
你可以看到過去這邊的指標
一度來到了將近80%左右
現在仍然只有30%幾%
所以我們要跟大家強調的是
即便今天看起來有提前壓低結算的味道
但只要結算過後
再加上新台幣
現在處於一個升值的趨勢上面
雖然今天從原本的升值6分
到後面變成小點一點點
但既然能夠台幣往升值的趨勢走的話
這對於外資來講會是一個利多
他們也更願意去把資金投入在台股上面
所以整體的籌碼看起來
不管是從不扣Ratio
還是現階段外資的空單
這個進空單
或者是為台散戶的多空筆
我認為其實都沒有這種說什麼趨勢
要馬上轉空的味道在
反而是在結算過後
台股真的有機會再往歷史高去做挑戰
聽產樂觀
當然在這個樂觀的條件之下
我們還是要去看一些
我認為在後面落後補漲
或者是能夠繼續往上攻的產業族群
CPO還是我的心頭愛
沒有 本來要誇你
因為現在9月降息機率真的掉下去了
對
當時在最豐身賀烈的時候
你是壓住說9月不會升息的
沒錯 我們是少數告訴大家
我認為9月不會升息的
那當然後面還有變數
我們就一步一步來看
現在的產業來講的話
公通在這裡因為NVIDIA已經宣布了
跟這個打造SpecChromX
其實這也不算是什麼新聞
那重點是在於NVIDIA
它持續的往這個方向推進
是在告訴市場
我們這個產業的成長性還在
什麼調單的傳言
那個反正在未來都會實現
所以AZ資料中心
真的進入了所謂細工時代
時間早晚的問題
這也是為什麼美股昨天的AXT
那XT漲幅能夠來到17%
原因就是因為跟零化硬機板
最有關的就是AXT
所以他在這邊的漲幅
即便昨天漲了17%
距離他的歷史高點還有32.9%
我們整理出來距離歷史高點的用意是什麼
代表他們還有落後補漲的空間
那像是coherent 或者是lumanton
我們上禮拜也有跟大家聊過
在昨天一樣是相對整齊的大漲
距離歷史高點大概都還有
超過10%以上的漲幅空間
一旦這些公司能夠追上歷史高的時候
我相信台廠的相關光通訊
應該也有機會在落後補漲一大段
這是我們的邏輯
因此整理了這張表格來提供給大家
在前兩個禮拜
我不確定8月初的時候
趙華還記不記得
我有給大家一張表
就是那個林化嬰從上游中游下游
有的
有那張表嘛
先說有再說
先說有
那張表格其實在這段這兩個禮拜過去
幾乎標股都在上面
林化嬰連亞全新對不對
大標
沒錯
那在這一波來講的話
第一個很多的光通訊都開始增上季線
那麼這一些就算沒增上季線
底部大概也打出來了
所以我們以前有跟大家分享過的包含
像是全新聯亞環宇ky
IT我們也講過
在這些漲完了以後呢
或者是他們漲到了這個階段
是不是資金有機會往外擴散
邏輯很簡單
你從上有的靈化音機板缺料到累晶
它其實間接著去證明了
光通訊這些光收發模組的需求槍
你光收發模組不單單只要用到
靈化音的累晶
不是只有雷射的光源
你其他相關的零組件
應該也要跟著用量提升規格提升
所以資金會開始往外圍
像是之前第二棒接棒的
像是6588的東點光電
或者是3163的波若威2489的瑞萱
都是在今年年初
這些全新聯亞先漲上去以後
他們後續接棒
那宣布怎麼選
我認為一樣都是從籌碼看
我們這邊一樣從鎖定率
來幫大家去做排列
當然今年的累積營收年增率
其實大家會發現
去年很多都是在損益兩平
就是沒什麼成長
可是到了今年累積營收年增率
甚至可以繳出這種三位數
就算沒有三位數全新也是30%的快速成長
因此我們在這裡會特別關注的
就是你鎖定率比較高的
或者是外資連買天數比較多的
或者是這些大戶持股有在增加的
那可能就是我下一階段會特別關注的公司
CPO很有趣
有段時間就是在講擴散效應
但這波反彈 大家是先看一線均
因為連亞領軍
現在從小明的表上看得出來
你又在看他的擴散效應了
之前幫我們講過的CPO相關的股票
真的是一路follow
大力光 ITKY全新
大力光雖然股本其實不大
但它的股價高
所以整個市值很大
這樣子或多或少
這個8月12號也沒過多久
都有不錯的漲幅表現
對 我們大力光真的講得非常的早
在這邊是跌下來
在季線附近
我說本一比不到20倍都是機會
到今天我還是看好大力光
即便從不到4000塊
快過前面的高
我跟你講過高我還是認為
還要再繼續創高
我希望
那以我們上禮拜分享的 IETKY 跟全新
其實到今天真的都有這個落後補償的空間
所以資金擴散效應我們就要來找下一棒
我認為下一棒很有可能會往部落位走
原因是因為部落位它本身在做的主要產品就是所謂的 OIN
OIN 是光纖連接產品
包含像是像環宇我們上次有講到的 AOC 主動式光纖
它也算是一種 OIN
那麼在部落位裡面 Shuffle Box
那 Shuffle Module
這些東西其實就是你要怎麼樣把光纖
一條一條的排在裡面
這個不太能做自動化
所以他要用到很多的人工
他的自動化程度一直都沒有很高
因此他比較偏向CPU裡面的後段
這也是股價為什麼在這波裡面
似乎都還沒有碰到季線
可是我們可以發現的是
以現在來講的話
上半年的營收年增17.47%
在目前還沒有大量的
這些Shuffle Box的出貨的情況之下
他還能夠年增17%
我覺得是很不錯的數字
因此外資雖然最近
其實好像也沒什麼動
但是他已經從原本過去
連續性的賣超變成沒有在賣
所以這種還沒有漲上去
有落後補漲的空間
而我認為波若威就可以去做關注
那另外當然他也有被納入
MSCI的小新股名單
所以這也算是一個小小的利多
那我們講到的波若威
我們就要想到瑞萱
因為上一次瑞萱也是在農曆年過後
好像送大家連續四天四根漲停
他那時候的話
也是沾上CPU的題材天天所漲停
算是這種所謂擴散效應小標兵的
手批 沒錯
那因為這一批來講的話
他是波若威外溢效應以後
我們講到波若威
你就要想到
那些Shuffle Bugs組裝
我說的有難度
所以瑞軒他在越南優差
越南的這些人工相對的
費用會比較便宜一點
因此他去做這些Shuffle Bugs的
後段製造的話是有利的
今年7月份的營收年增
就32.24%
而去年的EPS 1.22
所以今年在成長上去的話
其實換算下來
本一筆大概就是20幾倍
要找到20幾倍
本一筆的光通訊
沒有那麼容易
所以我覺得這一波
我們至少先看季線39塊
上方大概都還有超過20%以上的落後補漲空間
這個就可以去做觀察
那第二間公司就是6 5 8 8的東點光店
我們前面講了靈化鷹缺貨
那你到後面的後端靈組件
應該也要跟著用量提升
所以他在做的呢
其實是相對比較香的
這個叫什麼 濾光片
這個濾光片的話
他其實在1月份呢
還有參與了
叫威利富的現金增資
威利富是什麼
威利富就是在搶供35主化合物
什麼是35主化合物
零化因就是三五足化合物
所以得產能者得天下
以目前東點光電來講的話
今天剛好被夾在月線跟季線
往下回測月線以後
往上去挑戰季線
等於是形態
再接下來他就很像
我們上禮拜介紹的全新一樣
所以今年上半年營收年增132%
這在光通訊裡面算是不錯的成績
已經超過了去年全年的營收
所以現在的位階仍然很低
我個人是覺得在這邊
只要一旦能夠突破站上季線以後
後面落後補漲的空間
至少我覺得他的這個套牢賣壓
我們先看到130以後再來討論
因為這邊完全沒有量能
所以套牢賣壓一直要等到差不多到這邊以後
我們才會真正遇到
這種一樣是我現階段
CPO會看的公司之一
那第二個部分我們就要來聊設備了
因為我們過去聊設備很多都是CORUS
可是我們今天列出來的設備廠
都跟CPO的設備有關
對 我幫大家篩選過
那像今天還能夠漲停滿的樣子
揚存這一波很強啊
不容易 因為他營收數字是真的漂亮
還是要買基本面好的公司
另外包含像是前面漲很多的萬潤
今天回檔修正 拉了9%回來
但我覺得等一下我們來講
萬潤他已經有點擺動非常大
常常在賞亭或快跌停中間跑一跑去
因為前面一直在橫盤整理
來波動的時候就相對比較大
但一樣的萬潤在近期
他的新的題材就是跟CPU的設備有關
那我們等一下也會聊一下
關於近期的大標股油田
這波漲很兇
那他到底是在長什麼
等一下也來跟大家講
濕濕製成的紅素
FOPLP的冬節跟字帽
這些其實都是從過去
COOS設備有切入CPU的
同樣的我們從鎖定率來挑
你會看到這一種
真的大標股鎖定率都很高
猛力創高的鎖定率也很高
萬潤也是一樣
這種大於一的
大家都要稍微去多做一點留意
而且同時這些400張的
大戶有在增持
那398養成
這已經比較落後補長
對啊 我們會不會太慢了
會不會已經創高了
我們還來講他
而且今天還掌聽
沒有珠砲的紅大小明
我只能跟你講啦
在這裡要追的話
我個人也是不鼓勵
那你
那你好那怎麼樣才鼓勵
我們應該要講的是以陽城來講
因為他的股價已經變成了
將近要快要變得多頭型態了
這個月線準備要穿過季線
一旦月線穿過季線
他就形成四線多牌
所以雖然感覺股價創新高
但是他其實大概在最近這三個交易日
才開始放量
而且我們看到的是誰
你可以看到外資
也是最近這兩天才開始買
外資跑進來買
所以外資的成本大概也在這附近
那如果我不在這邊追價 我要怎麼做
很簡單 你五日軍線開始會往上走
所以後面這邊回測五日軍線
就是給大家上車的機會
因為畢竟你基本面 他是強勢股
然後你基本面的營收又開得出來
再加上過去 他是做所謂的徒步設備
我們以前講的時候 股價只有30幾會 40幾萬
這個徒步設備 你用到CPU一樣
他是同時都可以去做到同樣的工作
所以我覺得以陽城來講的話
這種回檔我還是比較偏向站在買方
做到什麼時候 做到外資他在這邊
開始油買轉賣 我覺得都來得及
那後面這裡的話呢
第一間就是今天將近跌停版的萬潤
那萬潤前面因為長得其實蠻多的
昨天漲停 今天跌停
今天差一度跌停
那這個我們要怎麼操作
反而對我來講會是一個機會
因為你如果在這邊害怕
怎麼樣會害怕會緊張
你怕輸就會緊張
那你想贏的話你會覺得很興奮
因為你終於可以減便宜了
這裡不管是外資還是投信都在買
大戶的持股連續兩周增加
而且我一直跟大家講
其實萬潤厲害的地方在於整合式的平台
它不是一台一台機器賣
而是我今天可以一站
你從最一開始怎麼抓取定位
後面點焦
我能夠一條龍的幫你做好
所以萬潤在這一部分
能夠提供的價值會更高
上半年的營收年增也已經開出來
創歷史同期新高
我相信下半年還會再更高
所以面對這種
你昨天漲停板
今天回檔修正
反而是給前面沒有上車的
投資人再一次上車的機會
那第二間公司3455的油田
前面也是標古啦
可是大家都不知道在標什麼嗎
因為他有油田
如果是這樣的話
他確實應該要標
那現在來講的話
因為油田他在今年5月份股東
會有通過新的現金針字案
在去年5月他也通過現金針字案
可是現在現針大家不是不喜歡嗎
大家不喜歡
可是因為他是說
我可以有這個權利
但他不一定要做
他去年就是說我通過現針案
但他股價漲到322
他都不發現針
現在在這裡
請問一下距離前高
他要漲到什麼位置
他才願意發現真
這個我們就可以有想像空間
那另外來講的話
因為CPU的封測的檢測設備
也是他這一波
下半年應該會有大量的訂單
開始去做任列
而且除了CPU以外
Covos也是在目前遊舔
他在往這邊去切入的一個
主要的一個方向
所以我們在這裡會特別去關注
他是因為外資連買四天
而且這四天的成交量
明顯很放出來
那我們去思考的
外資在這四天買的均價
大概也就兩百三兩百四左右
對比現在的股價258
說真的沒有差很多
等於在這邊進場
我們的成本跟外資
應該是幾乎一模一樣
所以我認為在大戶的增持之下
以及外資才剛剛開始進場買
股價的型態準備要等
月線往上翻揚以後形成四線多排
這種公司基本上就是要去挑戰
前面的高點
因此即便現在股價短線漲的比較多
但是只要有回測五日均線
我認為都是上車的機會
等於可能市值大的一些是
所謂的真外資
那市值比較小的中小型股的外資
就真真假假
但是也可能是公司派的
這類型外資
也等於是大戶看到
真外資回來之後
也願意更加的加碼台股
對 只要有錢願意進來
股價就有機會點火向上
好 這邊非常謝謝小明同學
謝謝
為什麼外資重要呢
因為我們講到現在
是一個成仙起後
如果下半年外資的錢
能夠慢慢的回流台股的話
他覺得是一個很大的助力
當然剛剛講到的
不管是CPO
或是延續著CPO相關的設備股
中大型的外資肯定是所謂的真外資進來
但是有很多的內資主力大戶
也可能藉由外資的民意在買
中小型看到真外資進來
那就可能所謂的擴散
因為我們的內資大戶怎麼樣
也會有信心
所以剛剛講到的
CPU一線均已經領先漲了
現在擴散出去
不管是設備或中小型的類股
都值得您做留意
廣告回來 微太要上場了
微太來救急了
很多人問說
為什麼旺戲連兩天
都有看到達到跌停板
事先開玩法說也不理想呢
不過另外來講兩個族群
一個散熱可以回後買
一個就是散裝跟貨櫃行運
運價正在往上走
雖然剛剛講到
看到半年報或是第二季的記報
成績很好
但裡面也有人是落難的
到底落難的是不是被誤會了
還是其實是一個好買點
就要來請教我們的黃金右下角
走啊 好
猥太
例如說旺戲師性可以玩
雖然都是屬於中高下骨
但以前外資對他們的展望是超級好
這次法說會後
尤其是旺戲連續兩根的停板往下跌
散熱今天是小回檔的
航海王
這個你長期關注的又來了
好 我們先來看一下大家很關心
最近有非常多的公司
看完法說
然後利多公告之後
反而股價是不漲反跌
別人都在反彈 他們都在跌
像什麼電影頭控
8月10號法說
就到今天為止 連跌6天
中壘也是連跌6天
那鴻海從8月12號法說完之後
其實股價也是拉回連續4天
那麼還有像加者
還有今天要跟大家聊的旺戲跟事情
KOL
都是在法國說會完之後
骨架是有呈現了一個下跌的走勢
是
好 我們現在看一下旺戲
那旺戲是全球前五大
晶圓探神卡的一個製造商
那他也是先進半導體
這個測試設備的一個廠商
那這一次的骨架往下做拉軌
說實話
我個人覺得他在前波段
高點拉軌這個幅度其實並沒有很深
他沒有深嗎
我覺得相較很多人的那種個別
腰站什麼的
對 他是屬於長多之後的一個拉回
那為什麼最近的拉回幅度比較深呢
我個人覺得第一個
除了這個利多消息這個公告之外
第二個就是說其實打法人預估
近的預估EPS是60塊到70塊錢
都以他目前的一個收盤價是5200多塊來看
其實他的本益比大概在這個
780倍
是 780倍
所以本益比在780倍的情況之下
這邊叫大家再去做這個追高
我覺得在這個心理上有一點點就是疑慮
在第二件事情就是
我覺得籌碼面是一個很大的問題
因為從前波段好久好久之前
投信就一直在買
幾乎是只進步出
所以其實最近看到這個麥芽來源
其實主要看到就是我愛這個投信
投信在昨天
他的投信的持股比例是25.45%
非常非常高
所以當這個所謂的一個股價
跌破這個月線
然後跌破季線之後
你難保不會看到頭性
會有一些不管是停損
或者停歷的籌碼會出來
所以這部分我個人覺得
其實最主要的原因就是
因為短線上面
頭性的一個籌碼再度鬆動
好 當然在法說會上面
可能對於未來的
至少以今年的展望來說
可能法人就覺得沒有那麼好
可是外資卻覺得
那你看明年 明年也很好
對 沒錯
好 那麼再來就是四星ky的部分
簡單講我覺得有一點點就是
預加之罪合換無恥
因為四星ky他們在做這種所謂的
預加之罪
好 我聽聽
我們在做這種IP相關的這種所謂公司
他們主要的收入來源有三款
一個只有單純授權IP
一個是做NRE 叫委託設計
再來就是在第三道就是做Tenkey
就是我除了委託設計之外
我要加做後面的
包括像是這個所謂的下單
然後去做一個量產製造的部分
那麼在施行K1
他在今年上半年
NRE的比重比較高
那NRE的比重基本上
跟毛利率有很直接的關係
NRE比重高
那基本上整體毛利率就會往上拉
可是NRE完了之後
就要做到什麼
下半段的時候
我整體的一個業務了
他整體的部分來講
營收會起來
但毛利率會幹嘛 會下去
所以大家會擔心說
他接下來的這個毛利率
會從原本大概是40%到50%
降到20%到26%
差這麼多
對 因為他的比重拉高
但是呢
展望明年上半年
NR1就拉起來了
毛利率會拉起來
所以我覺得其實這個架構來看
我個人覺得
大家對他這次的一個下跌
如果是在去扛勝毛利率的部分
我覺得是想太多了
想太多了 OK
反倒覺得接下來試劑
如果說我在拉股的情況之下
投信的一個持股
不要再出現大幅度的一個賣操
反而可以優先去做一個考慮
兩黨都是可能投信在聽完之後
覺得短線上面有點壓力
而做賣出
可是抵到一定的程度
然後外資報告其實都在調高平等
那明年的狀況其實都很好
對的 沒錯
好 那麼看完這個投信
覺得有疑慮的這個出現之後呢
我們來看一下投信可能
比較沒有這麼有疑慮的
好
反過來說
散熱族群之間的表現不錯
現在不管是美股或台股
基本上硬體相關的一個公司
都是比較受到市場上面的青睞
這邊可以到
包括像是一冷三熱的部分
看起來它在這個
AI伺服器的一個滲透率
是逐年往上做增加
從原本的個位數到兩位數
甚至來超過50%的一個比重
都是持續的往上做增加
那麼這個持續增加的背後
主要原因就是因為過去
可能這NVIDIA的一個伺服器
的一個機會有在用
但接下來包括像是AMD
包括像是Google
他們所推出來的這些所謂AI伺服器
基本上他們都會配備到
這個藝人的這個所謂相關的設備
那麼台灣在這個所謂伺服系
藝人散熱的這個設備的供應商
非常之多啊
那趕快來看看
這些的相關的這個藝人散熱的
這些指標股
他在經能第一劑跟第二劑的
跟EPS的表現
那我特別把他們去做一個對比
就是說我用他們EPS的QOQ
去做比較
然後再做排序
那成長服務最高的是建策
65.79%
他又回來了嗎
他又回來了
然後再來是麥克
然後紅準 台達電
齊紅 健準
富士達 雙紅跟高利
那有一些像富士達
他甚至還有一點小幅度的一個衰退
我覺得這主要是因為他在整個
所謂的產品的一個交接期
他會稍微的變得比較掉下去點點
但是我覺得他現在
他有在推出伺服器的滑軌
他伺服器的滑軌
也是綁定藝人人街頭的一種另外一種設計
所以對於這個所謂的廠商在組裝的使喚難度
會大幅度的降低
所以大家在講說這種所謂的
除了川湖之外有南俊
我反倒認為
富士達也可以特別注意
看到華鬼兩個字
現在眼睛就維持一亮
而且這也有通過
這個CSP廠的一些認證
那也可能接下來會陸陸續續的做出貨
好 那我們現在看一下就是3653的檢測
我們也曾經請委太在這樣的過程中
來解讀他 它怎麼了 怎麼辦這樣
好 那不過這波下來的一個過程
其實主要的賣壓來源也是這個投信
結果後來這波拉上去的呢
也是投信
好 當初說賽勒的軍樂片設計
兩片變一片 所以股價打對折
那現在 現在難道會恢復兩片嗎
其實後來在這個階段
我發現到他的營收的表現
並沒有出現衰退
就是直接就是打臉當時的那個傳言
或者是說他的營收的YOUI
甚至還逐月往上做成長
所以在這樣情況之下
這個投信沒有辦法
他們只好幹嘛回頭去把它做買潮
好 但買的位置也還可以
對 買的剛剛好
所以這一波其實很可能就是這個投信
不管是要去做作戰
或是拼積效做出出來持股的回補
那麼接下來呢
這個所謂的一個大園新廠
已經完工投散
所以對他接下來的一個營收
跟獲利都有持續的正面的加分
這個是已經有發動一段的這個建策
那這波段的底型也相當相當的一個完整
再來就是剛提到的富士達
那我個人覺得富士達有幾個優勢
第一個就是他的母公司是齊鴻
所以基本上在所謂的訂單的部分
我個人覺得他不太需要太多的一個擔心
那麼再來就是他有切入到
所謂的伺服器的一個滑軌的部分
所以他有點新的業務的一個推展
所以大家對他未來的想像的空間
會比較大
那如果說從他的股價來看的話
這地方似乎已經有出現
一個雙腳底的情況
這個波段往上再做走高
一口氣突破月線 季線跟半年線
再加上投信也是讓紙回頭
跟剛剛的建設很像
所以我覺得以目前來講
投信的持估比例是13.53%
還有往上去做加碼的空間
所以這檔個股有拉回
不管是回射景線
或者是回射月均線
我認為都是一個蠻不錯
可以去做留意的地方
上半年去投信不太青睞散熱
有一段時間我們都覺得他們有點委屈
但看得出來到了第三季
現在重新回頭佈局的話
反而散熱是主要組群
是的 好的
再來來看一下大家很關心的台達電
大哥啊
什麼時候輪到你
之前我們曾經討論過台達電
為什麼這波疊的比較重
然後反而光寶科拉上去
是
對 好
那當時我跟大家報告的是說
因為這個融資的部分
融資相對在這個地方
一直在做增加
但是最近我們觀察到
融資開始去做什麼
路路續續的退場了
所以我覺得這個地方
他的股價有機會在這邊去做一個租地
而且如果說沒有判斷錯的話
有可能會去做這種
類似投間底的一個表現
所以我想台大店這部分
大家也是可以特別做留意
只要看到這種線型往下的
就會去找VTY
VTY就就他這樣子
好
那我們再來講
極檔就是一樣是右下角的
剛剛講的很多都千元股
可能大家覺得貴
不過都是機會
現在的話
微太對於船產類也是持續的研究
散裝貨櫃其實之前你就有幫我們講過了
最近的海運股又開始出來了
第一個就是看到
就是波斯灣到亞洲的這種所謂的石油運費
開始往上去做調高
美統來到了
來到15.22美金
創下2005年來的一個新高
這是在油的部分
再來巴拿馬的運河船
也要調漲他的所謂的一個通行費
這也是創下2005年來的一個新高
再來就是遠東至美東的貨櫃運費
最近可能也是進入到傳統的旺季
也開始出現了一個調高
甚至來因何到水位
因為水位下降危害航行
這部分也要去加收一些所謂的運費
所以在種種所謂的運費
都去做調漲情況之下
我們認為接下來
海運它相關的這種公司
它的獲利就基本上去做提高
好 因為之前有幫我們先講過散裝
但目前看起來長得比較明顯的是
在貨櫃航運對不對
對 因為它是進入到
所謂的一個傳統的一個旺季
比較明顯的一個族群
好 但今天散裝有一些
以前我們認定的標股像四維航
就直接來跟你講聽
轉虧為營嘛
轉虧為營
轉虧為營最大
那麼這部分可以跟大家分享
其實這些所謂的非電子股的族群
他們在EPS的表現上並沒有特別的差
如果說一樣
我們從Q1跟QT做比較
像陽明就成長百分之300
長龍成長百分之93
外海成長百分之50
所以在貨櫃三雄的確確有
他們的成長幅度都相對比較大
其實包括像是新興考運成長更多
成長百分之350
這都是一個很明顯的成長
那我們先來看一下就是2609的陽明
ok 這波其實領長股是萬海
萬海已經創高了
創今年新高
ok 好 那創高的個股最近呢
市長上面比較不愛
不愛怎麼會創高
最近這一個禮拜
好 這個禮拜
我們看到很多創高都掉下來
創高都壓迴 而且壓迴很快
有時候會創啊 例如這樣子
好 那我們挑陽明原來是一位
第一個 股價近置比這0.58
是
有賺錢的公司
股價低於淨值
就是委屈
再加上接下來呢
他在整個所謂新船
還有在新增
11000TAU的一個新船
所以接下來
他的一個運力往上做提升
獲利也是有借往上做提升
那麼簡證指的外資
就在這邊做買潮
現在再做加碼
所以像這個地方的一個底型架構
擴研大體非常的明顯
這個是陽明
再來我們聊一下
就是2605的星星
剛剛看到說他的這個第二季的
這個EPS大幅度的提高
主要研究是為了他的處分
就是高燈輪跟青山輪
他有夜外
對 OK
但是即便是沒有夜外
他的這個獲利算法也算是不錯
那股價金字比大概是1倍左右
那現在大家看到了
底部型態打了將近有半年的大地
目前看起來剛剛要起漲
所以接下來大家可以特別做留意
好 之前其實散裝有率先幫我們講
這波股災跟散裝沒有關係
是
那現在看起來形態大敵又完成了
再來留意 非常謝謝維泰
謝謝薩華
維泰先解讀了兩檔指標高價股
旺西跟四星ky
都是在短線上
投信可能聽完法說之後
覺得短線上面有點壓力
或有點失望等等的
但是也可以看到
之後出的一些外資報告
依舊是對明年調高目標價的
所以呢短空長多的情況下
可以來看一下
這些已經被殺下來的公司
不過如果要凝聚所謂投信的共識
散熱的話可以說是第三季
目前為止投信非常喜歡的族群
而且像剛剛講的
例如富士塔又有切進新的產品領域
這個是很值得留意的
因為市場共識是比較高的
而散裝航運跟貨櫃航運
隨著報價的上漲
我們也是盯著報價
看著上漲
因為他們的股價相對都是在
比較右下角往上的
喜歡做一些資產分散配置的
這個族群確實也值得您做參考
今天非常謝謝三位朋友來到現場
台股雖然今天是一個比較明顯的小壓迴
但是這個時候我們剛剛提到了成仙期後
可以看一下外資回頭捕獲買什麼
投信在換股在換什麼
就會對我們接下來的方向很有幫助
也希望今天李台達安秀
電視頭子有幫助明天再會了
拜拜